y
[Música]
i
21 hondureños entre ellos la ex pareja
presidencial conformada por porfirio
lobo y la ex primera dama rosa elena de
lobo figuran en la lista
engels publicada recientemente por el
congreso de los eeuu y donde se señala a
varios ex funcionarios hondureños
acusados por corrupción está lista
además la integran 14 diputados del
congreso hondureño algunos de ellos
aspiran a reelegirse en las próximas
elecciones generales del mes de
noviembre en esta lista también ha sido
incluido el nombre del ex director de
inversiones estratégicas de honduras
marco bográn quien actualmente guarda
prisión preventiva por malversar
millones de dólares destinados a la
compra de hospitales móviles y al manejo
de la pandemia del cob y 19
recientemente el representante especial
del triángulo del norte del departamento
de estado de los eeuu ricardo su unidad
dijo que honduras pierde alrededor de
tres mil millones de dólares lo que
representa el 12 por ciento del producto
interno bruto de dinero que cae en manos
de funcionarios corruptos
[Música]
la reciente publicación de la lista en
gel en la que figuran cuatro altos
funcionarios del gobierno señalados por
corrupción podría tensar aún más la ya
difícil relación entre las
administraciones bukele y byd en el
presidente centroamericano se niega a
reconocerla aduciendo que su gobierno
tiene su propia lista donde señala la
corrupción supuestamente cometida por
líderes de la oposición en gestiones
anteriores en seguida el fiscal general
aseguró que no investigará a las
personas relacionadas o mencionadas en
dicha lista porque no es producto de un
mecanismo respaldado por la legislación
salvadoreña sin embargo organizaciones
de la sociedad civil consideran que se
debe iniciar una investigación de oficio
contra las 14 personas señaladas ya sea
por corrupción o por minar la democracia
del país es incierto saber el impacto
real que tendrá la lista pero analistas
han advertido que si bush que les decide
seguir ignorando la washington podría
responder con más nombres e incluir a
otras personas allegadas al mandatario
centroamericano y pasar de la
cancelación de visas a imponer otras
sanciones de tipo financiero
[Música]
diputados jueces magistrados líderes de
organizaciones de sociedad civil ex
funcionarios públicos y el ex presidente
álvaro colom son 20 los guatemaltecos en
la lista en yale señalados por el
gobierno estadounidense de participar en
actos de corrupción y antidemocráticos
en la lista no aparece ningún
funcionario del gabinete del presidente
alejandro giammatei que hasta ahora no
se pronuncia sobre la noticia pero su
vicepresidente dijo que la lista era
esperada aunque no se conocían los
nombres y los criterios que eeuu tomó en
cuenta tampoco brindó alguna reacción al
respecto algunas de las personas en la
lista rechazan los señalamientos otras
reaccionaron con sorna diciendo que la
mención es una condecoración la fiscal
general aseguró hace poco que hay
investigaciones contra algunas de las
personas en la lista mientras tanto el
gobierno guatemalteco se mantiene
cercano al estadounidense funcionarios
de alto rango de eeuu han visitado
guatemala primero la vicepresidenta
kamala harris en junio pasado y más
recientemente el secretario de seguridad
nacional